it's the beginning of march two thousand
sixteen so it's time for me to shoot
another update video in which I talk
about what went on in the month of
februari and what we've got coming up in
this month of March I'd like to begin as
I usually do by highlighting three big
things that either took place recently
or on the horizon the first of these is
that I have now taken over officially as
the editor of Stoicism today the vlog
that is sort of the organ for stoic week
and stoic on coming up this fall and
also for the stoicism today project so
i'll talk a lot more about that in the
March section another big thing that
I'll talk about in the februari section
is that we finally reach the 100 video
mark for the half-hour Hagel series it's
kind of a big milestone if anything
shows proof of concept for a crowdfunded
to do it yourself scholarly Enterprise
light like that I think a hundred videos
each half an hour long probably that
this that that shows that it works and
the third thing which I think people are
going to be particularly excited about
is that we are now in the process of
getting courses ready and I'm going to
be teaching courses not for credit but
for personal enrichment no longer on
somebody else's platform but on our own
reason I oh we're using our own Moodle
and I'm going to be creating a whole
bunch of different courses over time
there's a survey that I'll talk a little
bit more about in the March section but
I just want to tell you there's a link
to a survey so if you want to get in on
that action and say hey dr. Sadler it
really be interested in this course or
this course you want to look down below
and find that link and follow it out so
let's talk about the month of februari
I actually lost about a good week of the
month due to illness in the last week
and a half or so I did get some work
done but but it cut into it quite a bit
and that's a problem because February's
a very short month even with the leap
year right but we still got quite a bit
done so events the videos for these are
available link to down below three talks
or workshops one at the beginning of the
month was on Aristotle athens and
Alexander the Great another one about
the middle point of the month was on the
philosophical themes in JRR tolkien
works of primarily the Similan and the
Lord of the Rings trilogy and finally we
had a talk or actually a workshop on
Aristotle friendship and relationships
that we hosted at the the Hudson so
those are all available I did it had a
lot of work on on the plate in the month
of februari been engaging in some
philosophical counseling and tutoring
with clients we've been doing some
consulting with a local radio station to
help them in terms of organization and
underwriting and things like that I've
also been doing a lot of work with
priority thinking primarily working on
curriculum having to do with anger and
the emotions there's been a lot of back
end work on the stoicism today blog and
project getting ready to transition in
and I've done a little bit of academic
writing some work on some Marcel papers
that I eventually want to get out and
and get published I actually closed two
of my blogs a hard thing to do but it
really was time to make a decision about
that so virtue ethics digest and
Sadler's existentialism updates although
people are reading them and the articles
on them
going to be writing anything more in
them the good news is there's still
plenty of blogs out there that I'm going
to be writing in now video work I only
got four of the the six half hour Hagel
videos that I intended to get done again
because of illness but i did get four of
them done so that that's quite a
important mark we got to that 100 video
threshold and I did event videos for
each of those three talks those are all
available down below in the description
of the video I kept on releasing those
epictetus core concept videos that I
shot originally for the epictetus class
that I taught this this fall you can
tell how many of these videos i actually
produced for that course given that i've
been you know continually releasing them
and i also released another course with
curious calm an educational platform
that does Micro courses and short
lessons where you can find you know
video stuff with with handouts and links
to the text and questions that you can
answer so it's a bit more interactive
than just watching a video by itself
that was februari let's talk about march
where there's even more going on but
where there's a little bit more time to
get all this done as well so i have five
events lined up for march it's going to
be a very busy month as far as that goes
starting on the 10th March 10th at seven
p.m. at the brookfield Public Library
we're continuing the worlds of
speculative fiction series this time
we're turning to a great science-fiction
author very influential on many people
great favorite of mine as well as well
as a philip k dick who all talked about
in that but the the author is AE van
Voight the guy who wrote the null a
series the slan novels the weapon shops
of issue a lot of really interesting
stuff so that will be like I said
Brookfield public library
the 16th at 5pm this is central standard
time I will be holding another half hour
Hagel question and answer for the
general public in the Google hangout
format so if you're interested in that
sort of thing you want to you know
around that time look at my Twitter my
google plus and my Facebook feeds
because that's where the the link will
be showing up on the twenty-second of of
March at 630pm i'll be at the Shorewood
public library giving a talk for Women's
History Month on Mary Wollstonecraft
mary wollstonecraft feminist philosopher
and exemplar she's a real favorite of
mine I hope to do a little bit of
writing about her this this month as
well on the twenty-eighth I will be at
the Wauwatosa Public Library they've
invited me in to give a lecture on who
were the existentialist and what was it
all about so if you're in the area stop
on by and you can learn about that and
on the 31st kind of a big trip happening
because i'm going out to Virginia
Commonwealth University where I've been
invited to give a talk called what can
analytic philosophers and continental
philosophers learn from each other so
that'll be you know an interesting venue
to be in it's largely analytic and they
don't I don't think they completely
realize that I don't belong to the
analytic or the continental camp but
that I'm you know history of philosophy
and philosophy is a way of life can a
guy but you know it's a very interesting
topic so a lot of cool talks coming up
if you can join me at them do so make
sure to introduce yourself and you know
we'll chat so work all the things that I
talked about in February are continuing
through the philosophical counseling the
tutoring the consulting working for
priority thinking
stoicism today I'm now fully stepped
into the role and answering all the
queries and lining up blog posts but I'm
also doing a lot of work developing
these these classes and I've got a
survey available to you if you're
interested in like I said getting in on
the the process of telling me what
you're really interested in what you'd
like to take classes on I'm gonna keep
the survey open for a little bit more
and you can you can take it seven
questions these are the classes i'm
particularly focused on on developing
right now that that's not say it won't
be developing many other classes in the
future but you can see what they are by
taking the survey and giving me your
input i'm also going to be engaged in
quite a bit of marketing work which is
not not my forte but but as a set of
skills that i'm slowly acquiring because
i have to start lining up more talks in
in a number of different venues and each
type of venue and each type of talk
takes a different kind of skill set you
might say to get the word out about it
by the way if you're interested in
having me come in and give a talk or a
workshop of any sort send me an email at
Greg at reason I oh and will you know
we'll talk about if it's a good fit
we'll do it if it's if it's not you know
maybe I can suggest somebody else who
might be what else have we got going on
some writing I'm continuing that work on
Marcel which is a bit slow in part
because Marcel is a bit tough to write
on he's not all that that systematic
he's very very enjoyable to read a great
favorite of mine but it does take a bit
of time and I'm doing returning to some
some academic writing on Aristotle and
the subject of anger trying to get some
work done on a long long standing
project on a book on Aristotle of anger
popular writing I will of course be
writing for stoicism today as well as
editing depending on how much we get in
the way of submissions I may write once
a month or I may write every other month
if you know I don't want to clog it up
with my own stuff if we got plenty of
other things and that does appear to be
the case but I am going to try to get a
piece out this month probably on habit
and time which sounds like a rather
abstract set of sort of ideas but you'll
see when the comes up I'm doing some
writing for priority thinking's leader
time i'll also be hopefully doing some
writing not only in half hour Hagel
which I've been pretty good about but in
my my main blog that's supposed to be my
main blog or axis do know NTK and if I
get the time I'll even do a little bit
of blogging and heavy metal philosopher
I haven't done any work there for quite
some time but I've got some thoughts
brewing that I want to put down another
thing that we did was I put out the
first reason I owe newsletter finally
since we came back here to to Milwaukee
and you know tells you about news and
events classes that will be coming up
talks that are coming up any other sort
of things that are going on like for
instance i published an article recently
on and some that you might find
interesting on mercy and justice another
side project of mine but if you're
interested in being in that newsletter
list if you're not already getting it
i'll put a link to it in the video
description below and you can you can
click on that fill it out and you'll be
on the list and you'll start getting
those probably about you know twice a
month from from now on the last things
that I needed to talk about his video
work so this month i will get six half
hour Hagel done by hook or by crook
because not only you know if I committed
to it but the longer the less that I get
done on that the longer the project is
going to take and I don't want it to
take another four years I'd be happy if
it took another three years
I'm also probably going to be doing a
bit of a you might call it a fun drive
this this month trying to get more
people interested in becoming
subscribers for or not subscribers but
but Patriot backers for the half hour
Hagel series the videos of course are
free i make them available open access
on the internet best way to find them is
on the half hour Hagel blog because I've
got so many that there now curated in
each section but if you want to support
a worthwhile digital humanities project
this is definitely one of them this has
not been done before in this sort of
systematic overarching way by by anybody
up until this point even David Harvey's
marks lectures you know although they're
really great they're not going into the
sort of depth that I'm going into what
they have our Hagel so if you're if
you're interested in in throwing a
little bit of you know extra income this
way I'd be very happy for it it goes to
support a lot of good work like
providing the hangouts and and all that
epictetus videos I still have another
eight core concept videos believe it or
not from that class I must have produced
at least fifty or sixty during the
course of that that class so i'll be
releasing those hopefully over the this
current month and of course the event
videos I and if I have the time i'm
going to start shooting some videos on
other matters but i haven't quite
decided what those will be really
depends on time energy and workflow the
last thing i'll talk about too is there
will be another video coming out that
features me that's not in my channel but
is in the groundwork for the metaphysics
of mig tell the mig tau people are this
this movement that i'm sort of you know
looking at from from the outside they
you know they wanted to well at least
this guy Marcus wanted to bring me in as
a practical philosopher to talk about
some of the issues that they're
are running into and so this time they I
was interviewed about friendship so we
talked about Aristotle and cicero and
contemporary friendships and you know
how they how they fit in with the whole
matrix of you know contemporary society
it's a really great interview that'll be
coming out later this month i believe
and once it does i'll put a link to it
here on the video but you could go over
to his channel and check out the
previous interview that I did with him
on anger on the red pill rage so in any
case that's that's everything we've got
going on for March which is as you can
tell quite a lot of stuff i'm hoping
that i'll get all of it done and maybe
even a little bit more so that's that
have a good month and like i said if
you're if you're in the area for any of
those events come on by if you're
interested in supporting the half-hour
hagel project check out the Patrian page
and if you're interested in a sort of
you know speaking or workshop or
anything like that with an institution
or organization near you shoot me an
email and we'll talk about it alright
have a great month